comment vous situez est ce
qu'aujourd'hui les socialistes reste le
deuxième groupe du sénat a priori avec
les résultats que j'ai sur le plan
national
nous serons le deuxième groupe c'était
un objectif et c'est très important
symboliquement politiquement je suis
très fier de pouvoir porter le combat
d'une opposition socialiste au
gouvernement et à la majorité
sénatoriale porter les combats de la
justice sociale et à paris c'est
vraiment pour nous une satisfaction
parce que quatre sénateurs et sénatrices
socialistes c'était un objectif mais
dans le chamboulement politique de ces
derniers mois il fallait tenir bien le
socle a tenu et puis d'autres sénateurs
et sénatrices de gauche verts pc la
droite et s'est fait un peu éclaté
probable enfin la liste officielle des
républicains qu'il dirigeait à que lui
comme élu donc c est peut considérer que
c'est un succès parce qu'il est élu lui
même